Great. Let's 3D print it. Let's send it off. Let's get something. We started yesterday,
we're gonna have something to you by tomorrow. We're seeing a lot of that passion translating into efforts
to help. Open source is gonna get us out of this crisis. They're sewing face masks, 3D printing ventilator valves,
converting snorkeling gear into respirators, and crowd sourcing research into diagnosis and treatment.
In response to the COVID-19 pandemic, all across the world people who are locked in their homes
are still organizing in novel ways that may have a lasting impact on culture and society well after this crisis fades.
Communities can come together over this this knowledge sharing. Nathan Young organized
the Coronavirus Tech Handbook, which
started out as a one-page shared Google Doc
a month ago, and has grown into one of the largest and most widely used online libraries of tools
in the fight against the virus. We had just one single page and now it's 50 different sections.
The handbook is an internationally crowd-sourced compilation of tips, guidelines, and resources
that's edited by a 10-person team of volunteers based in the UK. Thousands of projects, it's got thousands
of people in the community. In communities around the globe people are pooling resources,
and providing assistance to neighbors in need. A throwback to the mutual aid societies that acted
as a social safety net before the rise of the welfare state. Just getting clothing, need some food delivering,
if you need, you know, if you need any help of any kind. As the severe shortage of personal protective equipment
became apparent, home sewing networks sprung into action to make improvised face masks.
There's a kind of community in sewing. Sewing people are good people.
Jan Brostek has been selling sewing machines in the Cleveland area since she was 16 years old.
Now she and her son Connor run the Pins-and-Needles sewing supply shops in town. One of our local
hospitals reached out to us. First they needed 10,000, and the day later they needed 100,000. So we developed
the pattern by their specifications. I have about 100 grandmas here locally at Pins-and-Needles, and my goal
is to have about a million grandmas on the internet.
After they made a tutorial video for their homemade mask, hundreds of thousands of people began
using the plans and convening to share tips and improvements on their Facebook page.
Donating all their fabric and cutting them all,
you can see this one's got Cleveland
Browns on one side and Cleveland Indians
on the other the pair says they're on
track to surpass their goal of making 1
million masks for medical workers we
actually brought in a chair yoga
specialist to do videos because everyone
was tired because they're making so many
mass in just days a solution to the
problem facing medical professionals
around the country schools businesses
and hobbyists have also turned their 3d
printers into micro factories for
medical equipment we're seeing a massive
willingness in the maker community to
get involved before larger manufacturers
can catch up as a manufacturer of ease
at scale printing the tooling this is a
very useful application of reading
printing 3d printing and additive
manufacturing also allow for the quick
prototyping and production of parts that
can convert equipment that is not in
short supply into life-saving medical
devices converting a smoking mask I
believe into asa respirator device we're
seeing application of frequency and
production of nasal swabs and tests
other di wires are developing diagnostic
tools that require no physical testing
kits such as by analyzing voice samples
that people record on their phones more
testing can actually potentially reach
every person on earth
dr. Rita Singh is a researcher at
Carnegie Mellon University who was
worked on applying AI to the field of
voice forensics since 2014 now there's
some diseases that are so clear here
more than 95% sure that we might be able
to detect now she co leads a team of 10
students at the school of computer
science on the corona voice detect
project which uses a machine learning
system to analyze a short sample of
someone's voice and determine their
likelihood of having the corona virus on
a scale of one to ten sings as their
system isn't meant to replace
traditional testing because it can't
give a definitive diagnosis but it could
act as a first line screening testing
system I tested positive for a covert 19
that is come on positive it came back
positive yeah and it sucks
they've started by feeding the system
public statements from kovat positive
celebrities and youtube posters but they
must crowdsource more data before it
becomes accurate enough for diagnostic
use we're soliciting data through our
website what would
together as a self-learning system and
the system will get more and more
confident as it goes forward that's a
very powerful thing that you're only
able to do because of open source and
the way that technology works today
bruce fenton began publicly warning
about the threat of the corona virus in
February and started several open source
initiatives you have a lot of volunteers
some very high level people whether it's
doctors scientists investors the first
day I announced one project and there
was 80 volunteers within a day and then
there's people running off and doing
their own thing even in this dark times
it is a nice light to say wow there's a
lot of quality people out there a team
out of MIT recently released specs for
$100 mechanical ventilator and
technologists around the world are
building on each other's open-source
data and plans it's particularly
scaleable and fast and you have hundreds
or thousands of people working on these
issues and people donating and
everything that's that's very very
valuable and it's very hard for a
centralized organization to duplicate
Fenton is also involved in folded an
online game portal that essentially
creates a distributed supercomputer
players use their personal computing
power to solve puzzles related to the
structure of viral proteins and then the
University of Washington is going to
take the most successful designs and
actually to prove that as a drug some
fold I tea by playing the game you're
actually helping out with university
research on the corona virus I have the
ultimate authority the President of the
United States calls the shots a possible
downside to decentralization is that
there's no formal oversight you don't
want anybody in a shed knocking up a
medical device here we have a simple
gate valve from the hardware store but
some makers say consumer protection is
possible without relying on a central
authority people can add to our document
literally by typing in the URL there's
no accounts there's just nothing and I
think a lot of people they get scared
initially about the idea that you know
won't somebody ruin it you end up with
tools which are more easily error
checked people go through the code they
improve things you end up with tools
which are better for privacy often
because you know you've not got some
company behind it which is trying to
take your data
the doctors in particular you know
they'll ask each other Oh does anybody
have this does anybody have the
guidelines for that and this YouTube I'd
like to show you how to matter
by one ventilator to ventilate - or for
patients simultaneously with the help of
this video
Gotye and his team retooled each
ventilator to help save multiple lives I
think you'll be great if so many of the
epidemiology models we'd seen have been
released to the public there was nothing
about this crisis which was
unpredictable it's based on a
feasibility study that was published in
2006 you know Bill Gates has been
complaining about this for years this
was an entirely predictable crisis which
with a few billion pounds of investment
could have been any more less entirely
avoided fully self-organizing groups
with social welfare programs have sprung
up in a matter of weeks and they're
continuing to evolve in complexity these
communities so far are doing all of
their structuring they are deciding
what's important in resistance from
managing it for keeping people's data
safely using these systems for managing
money and so our mutual aid section is
now about four systems if technocrats
and bureaucrats and politicians try and
monkey with guessing how the world is
going to work it's never gonna work
this idea that the defense production
act should be used like ask wool has the
federal government proven themselves to
be particularly competent so far the
words about a pandemic at this point o
or not at all and where we have it
totally under control
the tests are beautiful anybody that
needs a test gets a test and the tests
are all perfect US lawmakers have now
proposed a vast biometric surveillance
system that would persist well beyond
the corona virus pandemic but Fenton
says it's possible through decentralized
technologies to realize the benefits of
contact tracing while preserving user
privacy we need to have control of those
things some private keys and that would
be a perfect fit for something like
tracking where everybody involved is
voluntary and nobody can find out
anybody's information without them
sharing it the 2020s may be off to a
rough start but efforts such as these
showed the potential for technology and
human ingenuity to empower individuals
in the coming decade even when they're
sitting on their couch just you know
it's a search if you want something you
want to be involved in there are
communities growing all the time there's
communities for volunteers the teachers
the doctors even if you're just grabbing
some food for your neighbor I'm just
very moved by the amount of work that
everyone is doing just for everybody
else there is a really vibrant and
optimistic thing going on here if we can
keep pushing this we can fix it approach
because it turns out we can